you
[Music]
[Music]
and we're back yes we are however thinks
looking but we give you all of the frame
turn backward I positioned you left left
left left
hamburger sign Oh delicious our friend
here was hungry and I thought I'd
actually not notice the Simon I played
last time so I'm money why would he
check it out
now go inside let's get on in here we go
okay we've got subtitles on so you guys
can so basically so we can talk through
that the cutscenes and you guys still if
you haven't played the game yet so you
know what's going on all right I'm just
gonna crank my volume so I can hear a
little bit okay it looks like a normal
store all right sab let's see what's
going on investigate that store anything
on the shelves catching your eye I mean
obviously instant noodles instant
noodles always catch my eye okay or
someone's blood oh yeah we need to clean
up on aisle what is this so three big
clean up yeah this guy I'll be back for
you okay I mean I don't like to be a
pessimist but I can't guarantee that we
can hold to that promise okay so keep
pushing through keep pushing through
here it sounds like there's something
going on
now if I didn't make myself clear
earlier on I am a chunky gamer and when
it comes to horror this is gonna be
quite something
fairness is an exceedingly gory game I
tell you what this is also the first
time the first one we've ever seen the
frame counter dropped below 100 yeah we
were 6 maybe it's a committee to the
score all right keep pitching that son
of a [ __ ] come on please so it moves
around a lot
all right so 3 3 3 seems like the magic
number job good job
where you going so you need to find
something so like doesn't look like I'm
gonna be able to get through here just
yet yeah you need you need a key oh
thank you I'm Noah oh no door expert but
I'm pretty sure you need a key
so maybe the zombie have one no aha do
you see what I see 7 yes many sexy
posters sexy posters and a key Pizza
Pizza it's still good
fortunately you can eat beets is it's
not worth wasting any Emmy no no to the
earth like the number one tip I was
gonna give you and playing this game is
conserve your ammo also run away from
the zone pieces skimpy iron I'm out I'm
served the ammo
please Ovie's ok have you feed the right
way I mean I think flowing the right way
[Music]
hey it's okay he's going he's looking
the wrong way
alright so you
you need to figure a way past him yes
that's good my I'm gonna go with the
Dodge yep
all right use the key one key please use
use there we go
very good very good I guess all right
okay
oh we came back for him what should I go
promise what's that exactly he's gonna
get you yeah the chopper this guy does
like a pro sorry
I'm sorry we close close close to
zombies people elide hmm
now if you haven't played the remit
before choice the beginning is to me yes
we chose Liam they particularly reason
we're safe because I played the
beginning with Claire a while ago at a
friend's house okay that's the reasons
know how this cutscene said get ahead of
this well captain said well so far uncut
scene service bina and not a bad shot
I'm gonna say cutscene said let's see
what its drivings like okay
now I gotta say be good as someone who
played resin evil six
this game I love how reckon beginning is
it stamps stamps intention of not being
that type of game that's back to roots
it's so good this is gonna be terrifying
and you are going to feel powerless
yes but the thing is so i played i would
say the first couple of hours of the
game that's or i'm intent to finishing
it later but so i should be able to
guide you but if you're right really
efficient but guy may have played really
slowly so we're really efficient you
might get me i can't promise anything
but i'm not gonna spoil anything I
mainly get it laughs I'm scared
that's my plan well I I really
appreciate that and it's good to know
that I would be doing exactly it's it's
really nice doing this all right cuz
usually when we when we stream I'm
playing yeah and you get to watch and
laugh at the things I do like it's a
treat thing so we've got the intro
cutscene here we're running the cane is
running fast we're at 209 trains per
second I don't know if you can see that
it is a small counter in the top
right-hand corner there but when the
background is black you can check it out
so we are actually we actually pushed
two things above for like a little bit
above there suggest eat
PC reusing mic I'm not cranky whereas
people has a stop thing is over settings
as well as the the light with the grass
we talked about earlier it was like an
Amber or a Red Alert
depending on if you might get Collett
cheese no the guy says we might get
glitches cuz they're precious little bit
fireman I don't know I like live days I
mean just kind of a stress test it's not
the fact that we're getting is actually
I mean for me I have to be stressed the
entire time now it's gonna be stressed
about the hardware I'm gonna be stressed
about the game yeah that's not gonna be
a problem it's gonna be very relaxing
streams for an affair I feel like if if
it was pushing us into sort of the the
Amber Alerts the Red Alert that that
will be seeing frame rates lower than
150 okay I was gonna say is on the
laptop here I have the chat open on
YouTube so if you have any questions
yeah feel free to throw them in any
comments if you want to make fun of subs
that's so far it's good shooting so yeah
but you know if he gets it he gets
rattled and fact actually he'll woods
he'll Widger on said lucky shots I think
that was the one shot it was the insta
headaches yeah yeah yeah well I'm you
know plenty of those to come don't worry
it's gonna be just like you know Wild
West style quick shooting I mean it
won't be at all it's gonna be slow
calculated are you gonna try and the
thing is this you know Raccoon City yeah
in this game full of zombies you're
gonna you're gonna train kill them all
no I mean I know what the deal is I know
what the deal is that basically ammo is
going to be hard to come by
so I will attempt to dodge duck dip dive
and dodge
I can't guarantee but I won't get
punished in the neck for him
you can dodge a wrench you can dodge a
zombie yeah you can dodge a guy can
dodge a zombie if they can dodge a
bullet surprise not going well
Claire oh there's a truck
he was oh it's this guy you gotta be
kidding
see it's just that it's just burger
sauce that was yeah he's fat was just
burger sauce
peaceful future minashi
now if anyone played the original game
is like I don't remember this scene this
because you know this this is a remake
not a Rhema curve every master then we
master yeah yeah it's a you know a
remake of the game in the same way that
you know the Final Fantasy you can be
renamed like it's based on but it's not
identical although this this I think
this is a bit for people who played in
between
and what to see and remember on there
where it will be arriving very soon good
assuming set doesn't die well I'm not on
fire and I did get thrown against a car
I think that's just the rains
oh she's fine
for half a second I was gonna be like
man playing a story being real short on
fire happy such an incredible troll
yeah there's like yeah play this
character forwards is not the way to be
go nice you already used the queue for
quitter which is a bloody this is
basically the moment where you dodge the
zone okay zombies
oh I remember the rule of video game
said what's the rule of video games
follow the light follow the light follow
the light there's a light over there
okay this way if you like light still
then it's right she'd just point away
down here past the goofy baby that
following that fire okay all right Leon
ah there is the station the station kay
so I'm gonna wait until we get into a
place that feels even vaguely safe
before I take a look at the graphic
settings that we've we set out a good
I'm going to follow the path of least
resistance and probably most fire
killing kids almost there I'm gonna go
behind him ice let's know it's the
homely Touches that really make a city
good job thank you all right are we in a
stressful are we okay you're okay
yeah you're safe here saying I mean are
we ever safe so happy so why exactly did
we go for Resident Evil to as a game to
sort of bear take a look
well because it's it's new it's very
beautiful and it really lets you Cosima
Dublin sayings you have a lot of control
I'm going to wine okay options please
graphics please okay so so what you talk
me through what you've set up as you can
see where it says graphics memory it's
in Redis there but it's just red so I
think I think we're gonna be okay but
what I like about it is it tells you you
know we actually have a little bit of
overhead in like the processing load and
the image quality but and as you as you
go down through the menus the game tells
you like which is gonna affect
processing load and image quality on
anti-aliasing although have maxed out
yeah we found to crank it higher we need
to increase the percentage the scale the
resolution scaling one would have
thought the max was 100% but actually
you can you can push them never yeah so
we've we've brought it down to 6
gigabytes of texture quality pressure
will go 8 it'll go to 8 this is where
the warnings begin yeah that's right oh
really
red alert so we've got it at 8 because
the sorry I'm an 8 gig oh yeah the
graphics card that we're using inside
the obelisk gaming PC well the the
obelisk goes all the way up to an Nvidia
GT sorry an NVIDIA GeForce r-tx 2080 yes
which is what's in here and that is the
one we got in there yes so as far as
this this PC is concerned we've we've
SPECT it to the highest it'll go yeah so
we are going to run the game on the
highest settings we can just slightly
above recommended we are at 1080p but
that's because this displays 144 Hart's
1080p so we gonna match that hence the
frame per second counter
obviously you guys over the stream it's
gonna be 1080 60 so obviously you guys
won't see the hundred forty-four
you need to monitor it is there any way
but yes no we streaming is at 60 mm-hmm
okay are you happy with you said I'm
happy with you selling everything is at
max we can all do one other thing ari is
the goon
it's the shadows where the shadows find
me their shadows shadows I think was
further up it's the only one that's not
maxed contact no no no equality
yeah it's hi he's thinking we could go
higher she's thing on max oh that's a
jump it's a big jump and I'm gonna
handle it so okay let's go back to let's
go back well let's leave it the C gun on
that let's return yep
return again return alright president I
shout into the PlayStation okay so I'm
gonna try not to tell you where to go
all right
is anybody here he's nice how many I've
not been to that many police stations
but I've never been to one with that big
statue in it thank you yeah no Lady
Justice I mean who else could it be it's
not this is certainly not lady Lady
Liberty I mean cousin she'll be holding
justice or skills right she's got a
spirit here when she's lady violence
maybe she is I reckon she's lady vols
anyone know what lady this is it's the
three ladies the apocalypse Oh Katie
Justice lady violence and Lady Liberty
all right first names Bray yes I will
have that thank you very much okay now
if you are pick up pick up the ability
visit the billets is it worth saving oh
I will absolutely have those thank you
so I understand that a typewriter is for
safe that's true yep I'm gonna save away
so what if we go here that's a storage
locker absolutely no would you like a
tip yeah I always so that key yeah that
well weren't key what did that do that
open the door that we escaped through I
think you're gonna be back there again
that's a smart thing you need a key I
expect no probably not
okay so flicks door again there you go
and now you have an extra space for your
ventra you are you're wise so what's
going on in an RPD land let's watch
hack the planet Leon there has to be
someone here there is that guy he's seat
look he's conserving his shots he's
played this before he needed his hand
free go on eat your muscles use at the
academy not to get strong all right
reinforcements East hallway do you for
that ok that's where we will have you
wanna go east alright gonna do my best
alright remember you're never eat
shredded wheats is East that way ok the
map screen actually let's talk briefly
about the map section played this before
so let's go do that basically you'll
notice yeah yeah let's give you a
microphone fine whatever who needs it
you can see that for every area in the
map red means there was more stuff to be
found within it means you found
everything there aints cleared yeah so
yeah it just means there's more stuff in
here but you're gonna come back here
with a story anyways so sure right now
you want to go east east it is again for
you
if we can try and get through this store
here although that red Jaggi line
doesn't fill me with confidence so Bob
Jones 1980 says it can be Athena statue
and then someone says sorry deep said
yes shield and spear might be Athena
brackets also our all questions could be
what do you mean by owl explain okay
we excel CM says crank it up don't worry
I like that attitude that's just what
happened sorry see we will let your the
monkeys whatever you say okay you're the
boss
okay so do we want to send it as high as
possible let's just set yet no that was
already that was already on Aaron today
so many of the shadows do show okay and
then shadows was that the quality yeah
that's max now okay so that's max when
rendering at 1080p but when you have the
ability to go even higher than that we
do okay
so return refirm that's all done return
return return all right so we cranked it
let's see what happens yeah I'm seeing
170 frames a second yeah I think we're
gonna be okay but we are in a dark
hallway ah okay when I put the spray
painted this refers to spray paint
confess first aid spray set of course
but I don't think that's gonna help the
fuse box that's all no a good tip I read
oh yeah playing rest on evil - is touch
every door touch every don't hit that so
well done keep touching those doors hey
I'm just gonna watch out for things cold
drink much every snack machine that's
just a life skill I've been told for
just general day today you got this even
Leon believes in the UK sorry sorry if
I'm looking around a lot this is
genuinely my first time I think this and
I don't want to be caught off guard okay
it seems like a good idea
Oh buddy and we got a friend on the
floor again we are not Zombie zombi your
Nam B I'm gonna go with non be I feel is
a non be well okay cool
better than that add bullets bullets
okay what's this a light switch
hey okay it's less scary now alright
we're in a we're in a recording studio
so it's pretty much like they were
wearing oh we forgot our flags know if
I've got our flags I've got a I mean All
American flags but we should get
something we should get some British
ones yeah weird that
anything anything to have here
not really yeah well I'm touching this
door and nothing's going so I'm gonna
head back out and see well why is the
press room is blue okay so I'm gonna go
out of here
head hang a left well and see if I go to
the bathroom first or you want to go
straight to the what watch me I mean
given that what we're about to encounter
it's probably going to get me right in
the bowels let's go to the bots
let's be smart about this not a thing
all right push on okay somebody's in
progress
nothing the woman's the lead I'm not
technically allowed in here can
apocalypse okay you get a you get a
scavenge everywhere can't see sir I
really should check all the cubicles
clean-up on cubicle T although some of
these first day tanks were spray paint
you're gonna make such a mural they can
play the game suggesting I'm gonna get
injured yeah for shadow you somewhat
all right check
can I come I never start we're still
pulling down more frames than we need
sir 157 frames I mean do you want to
really crank it let's keep playing until
we see some zombies okay we can do that
let's find out what can you wish there's
some dead guys on the floor here
hail wood Garin says watch out for jump
scares that's a that's helpful so friend
here is a chain yeah
can I shoot it I don't know why are you
trying let's go
I mean do you think you could shoot a
chain in real life I mean obviously I
don't think that you could do that in
real life but I know what this game like
i know what games are but i know so they
don't have a lot of ammunition I'm gonna
I'm gonna try no okay well that's a
bullet gone that's a bullet I'm never
getting back oh oh no that one not that
one
save him didn't check my corners come on
you can do it come on he's making a
fella come on we got you he might be all
right do you think it's gonna be I think
he's gonna be all right
thank you again is he gonna get stuck
back in or you gonna fill in for sir no
I wasn't wrong and I wasn't some of them
didn't come ours I was grim but somebody
call an ambulance like video game powers
right yeah for anyone like squeamish
you've probably already left
oh here we go okay so I presume I can
relate some of this to my like I was
gonna say probably Safina see I love it
I love how it's like what are the police
do here oh we're buried in the paperwork
meanwhile I'm gonna do some doodles
doodles in it keep looking it's more
doodles he likes to do unicorns yeah
goddess he's an Lions I think it's a
lion okay don't know well that that'll
be a puzzle they're young I'm not saying
it's definitely a puzzle except it is so
he seems okay he's probably gonna be
able to reanimate you think
he seems like a canal
Oh
Oh compliance I've got plans and they
take require me to be elsewhere I'm not
going I do
oh yeah nice if you stand still your
reticule too small a reticule reticle
gosh did I just run back did I dance in
the room with the zombie in it okay
is that where we want to be
no you I think you want to go back leave
I think I want to go back I've got a a
sort of a go back bye oh god oh god oh
oh I'm gonna be quite moved by the
auction tell your coach look I am loaded
up I would suggest cheating it I am
loaded up with spray spray I will but
it's not the right way there's a cold
bricks thing here we go here we go here
we go the way you came in but it was
this the way I feel it under the thing
no I don't think okay yeah
if you're ever in a moment of stress
when your good friend said just remember
he will be no help whatsoever
so what the FPS bouncer is there is
actually a direct relation to my heart
rate yeah there was another did anyone
know what the s and Leon's middle name
is yet ah yes he just didn't say there
he just says Leon Kennedy so sobbing he
maybe it's something only his mom calls
him when he's in trouble
Leon s Kennedy clean your room it's
Steve Chu make some bets you guessing
Steve Steve okay I'm gonna go for
Sasquatch Sasquatch Ken it's a family
name let's see what the chats been
saying once they have bathrooms in the
entire game boilers but also those so I
don't have to check any more game that
is actually quite a relief in its own
you no pun intended way what do the cops
on the other side of the station do when
they have to go to the virus began maybe
that purse annotation it's possible is
that where the crooks go as well
they still call crooks know eventually
Punisher six seven nine one says oh
sorry I'm discounting from the story
here Oh chat says Leon Scott Kennedy as
she got everyone saying everything Scott
course it's like are you sure it's not
sasquatch I think it's quite sure take
stop what is this what is this it's his
lightsaber don't make my mistake if you
see one of those yeah if you see one of
those things animal form or not Annie
won't hesitate farman I don't think
hesitations been my issue my issue has
been friendliness hello
go around
okay was it a knife yes coming oh okay
now which is actually very useful okay
cool
all right well done you've got past the
very first bit mmm and you've obtained
the combat knife space ready click - can
be used to counter-attack when you're
caught by an enemy now I've not managed
to do this yet and can only be retrieved
once you defeat them okay right so
basically if I get a tab you're gonna
stab it in its face okay that's gonna
fall hit space bar got Joe needs it yeah
yeah yeah all right do you want to do
some healing up how's your heels heels
actually of the fact that fact alleles
like I'm holding holding your guts in
yeah you might be a caution okay I am a
caution I am a question okay say let's
see some first a little spray paint one
little spritz okay yeah feelin healthy
golden there okay so let's take a look
at the map hey you found everything in
the main hole mm-hmm that's exciting so
we can ahead through well actually you
do have a little exclamation mark maybe
check that out I will that's exactly
where I'm gonna go okay so so far I've
not been seeing any issues other way did
I go the wrong way you might want to
save it our shortest safe yeah me as
well so there oh I think we're seeing
some little them with their minor
wibbels so that's one thing that is
different for me you don't you need
reams of em over tape for the
typewriters thankfully you can save any
time you want nice alright baby justice
it has to say you haven't seen this yet
sounded military creating on a note
that's my knife that's you standard
military grade should come in handy in a
pinch hit them with a step Hey attention
Seb okay so yeah okay well obviously I'm
gonna need some items to work this oh
yeah
Bob Jones Nathan and he says he's gonna
be a zombie later for sure I think what
is he referring to me no I may be but I
think officer not long for this world as
I'm going him
a zombie okay and some some dial select
now what I can do cannae willy-nilly
your dials as you see what are you gonna
do I'm gonna check okay so why don't one
of my backup first okay and look at this
lion okay I think so yes and then let's
take a look at the night book again well
first up we go back to the previous page
okay previous page
so this is like you know when we saw him
on the on the the raccoon TV thing
earlier and he was like oh yeah here
there you go we need to complete some
puzzles to move a statue clearly which
is hiding a hidden staircase which is
going to take us underground is I
presume that's a lift of some sort or
elevator yeah into question which means
everything's okay room yeah then up a
ladder into the parking and then we
probably Hotwire a car and we are gonna
speed our way out of here may drift
okay so lion-o do you know what sorry
one little thing go back again oh yeah
no note how they've because he's drawn
the unicorn or horse sort of Helen in
like strong they've made it like look
like a smudge through I'm glad we can
still see it yes
lion so lion branch burb okay I'm going
with an old line Bart brunch bird yeah
let's go squid hey squid lion ROG snake
herb okay confirm hey chop stomach you
get a line head line medallion okay mmm
where'd you want to put it in your
inventory I'll put it there perfect okay
can i cuz it clearly clearly needs to
live here can I just pop it right in
let's find out that would be viewed
inventory management SAP yeah well I
like more the best there's nothing I
like more than good inventory management
okay
okay that was a start hey it was right
yes use the statues to get medallion
says lies okay hmm okay let's take a
look at the map so I don't think we we
need to save again yeah okay you're good
okay leaving you I appreciate where you
gonna go
I'm getting through this door uh looks
like you need a spade
ah I see I'm not like a literal Spade
like a key with a spade on it gotcha
yeah no problem
yeah let's take a look up here upstairs
a yeah okay right so this is a whole
nother area according to this and it's
red which means oh yeah looks like it's
again what can a police station has this
setup is this normal I'd say it's pretty
normal I mean of the police station so
I've been into you before of which some
I'm glad that at least the the item slot
for ammunition counts as erm okay the
ammunition slot is something that I can
provide that yesterday I'm not sure if
there's a limit that I might like
previous games or something was I think
hitting an ammunition limit is probably
something we don't need to worry about
for me good point is either side but
remember where did the map say the map
said it's already blue my bad it's try
it try the door
okay okay door opened
oh nice check your corners checked check
the vending machine shirt in the bin
touch all the bins okay what was the
safe first
herbs no do you are you familiar with
the herbs I am familiar that they are
quite medicinal right oh sorry that's
not a safe that's a computer that is
absolutely safe that's a safe that's
what I said that's what I saw oh do we
have a code I don't think we found any
code celery I don't believe is that
powerful a code
unless it's in your orientation letter I
would say it probably isn't
welcome to Raccoon City PD here are safe
codes it might be on the pamphlet is it
guys a pamphlet wrecking city open safes
did you know while we're at the home of
pharmacy talk giant umbrella corporation
ravine city is a vibrant dynamic city
with a long rich history of its own in
this guide we only see just a few more
unusual points of interest something I
want to know maybe I want to go here
building his center town wasn't always a
police station in fact it used to be an
art museum all right hence why it's such
a thing okay and has a statue in it of a
goddess various features like the
unusual clock tower and goddess statue
in the main hall remind us of the bike
on easily they actually explain it I
like this just a few blocks is an
orphanage you're definitely gonna mind
up there okay orphanage is known for not
being scary locations it's good it's
good
cool all this in the pamphlet come to
Raccoon City we have to the police
station and the orphanage and we need
the right thing for that okay so I think
I'm heading back downstairs now let's do
it okay check your corners okay cam are
you probably notice I'm playing with one
headset on and one headset off mostly
just so I can hear you ignore the entire
stream yeah but I can't say that my
right ear is nice and cold why is this
there do you have such a horrific
disease I do
Bittan many times in the neck I know
we're playing with the the full omen by
HP rig here and the headset the
mindframe headset that we yes legitimate
your cooling yes so it's not like a you
know it's not like it's making sure it's
well ventilated on a fan actually you
can tell the other side gets quite warm
and because of the refrigeration I'm
just gonna just cuz it's so easy to do
yeah but if you're doing along a long
session of Resident Evil 2 and you're
worried about your ears of reading want
me now wait you think need to go I think
I need to go back no okay thanks I go
through that door on the other side what
have you acquired let's see what I'm so
glad you're here what a night if you
lost her right okay let's stop there
what
built using knife for Oh could I eat the
fuse box not that box okay maybe the
thing that you're looking at this thing
maybe that thing we she previously
couldn't but admittedly I didn't try but
uh yeah that totally works
second day totally imagine this I'll
take a I'll take a second Oh mo you
didn't write in the MOU no yes well I'm
not I've not had to shoot many things
well for a while you really live and you
gun reload now you've not there you go
okay
see that is a bus step off those who
served honor of those have served
raccoon a trick a tricking City oh
that's a lot of this is where they bring
the perps in yeah why is it I think
there's all the scratching on the wall
that's ominous no it's not that's just
that's normal
okay okay and goodbye lights hello okay
okay answers all right guys what a treat
I really I'm good do you play a little
vent for a game so I have played horror
games do I play a lot of them absolutely
not oh here's our guys zombie anomic I
say he's giving off an omni vibes but
I'm gonna get punished I'm about to get
punished for doing this
but okay he's quickly an ambulance
yeah pulling the face that I call when
snacks are about whoa what happened to
him how did you get up there is he got
broken pipe in his back he does seem in
a man to me he has been impaled on
something up there yeah he has how did
he get up there oh window so you haven't
found me yet but if you had found some
boards you can actually board up the
windows okay
that's why it's like a threat okay well
I look forward to things jumping through
the window then I won't be able to it
than that I can tell you okay that's a
big scratch yeah yeah that's a big
scratch it sure is friends I'm really
sorry if I'm playing this at a pace that
you find nauseatingly slow if you had
boards okay you can use the herbs to
make a nice window fill it up with
potted plants I was gonna come through
here but I really don't want to disturb
the folk you know what let's just let's
just pretend you on there oh yeah no no
it is oh you're just gonna I'm gonna do
ignore it's gonna leave with me huh she
probably doesn't remember that I'm here
get ready to quick turn in case she
don't mine
okay well I'm back up to my 24 at least
you go you got bills for days okay well
I'd say both guard up which which one
which one I think I think the one you
came through
another one the other one heavens
greetings greetings friend nice come on
Sam yes I'd the door with you you stay
there cuz I got some reading to do
[Music]
so I think I just upgraded my map a
little I did mm-hmm
it looks like we've made some progress
in this room yes okay good all right
I'll take that there's actually more to
pick up I don't believe in here honey
things he becomes just the mi maybe I
was it no that does that to you okay
record of offense we're turning the
station into a temporary shelter due to
the massive sudden outbreak all police
personnel have been instructed to make
the safety of the citizens their top
priority as we try to accommodate as
many of them as possible all and then
the attacks begins people have been
injured a mob attack attack we're not
sure we can fix any of our comm
equipment so we're all cut off there was
another clash disarray David one of my
relative brother Dave Oh God
okay I'm back let's oh no that's a lot
of time we know we can't shoot you
so we can't shoot her why you do you
stay down
Wow no you know what forget that I got
plans
see when I play this game I I kill I
have very little island well I just
three times and then another time I wait
till they're like dead dead
oh god because the way this happens oh
you know what let's not stand in front
of the door for the inevitable bursting
through but that's it like I've got em
where else can I go here and so in the
room with the zombie yeah actually there
was something you missed okay
like I routes you could have gone but
you because you're too busy worrying
about the zombie that's right there what
the hell
nice no she's actually dead Wow he just
kicked her those cool good job right
back home this time reload it we get oh
alright look at the map pay attention
said blue butt oh yeah off to the left
see okay so I think yellow tape there's
a bit of em before shadowing in this
game bat is shot
Oh number okay somebody can't go back so
I guess we're going for it you should
just generally check the bodies you find
okay it's usually advisable to check
them because they might have a murabbi
chock-full over might be back in okay
back in bullets this guy just wants the
vending machine to work and I feel his
pain nice okay I think he's dead good
job you get a lot of these yeah it's a
it's a bit of a step forward trick
alrighty let's take a look into locker
number
oh I could just go through them
systematically or you could look at the
lockers okay hey gifts do won't eat
another knife well look about your
keypad again wait where you just were
that the device that you looked at first
look at that hmm what do you notice like
ticking it see yes you look at it would
you notice what's missing
ah right okay so we're looking at any
numbers except ones with two and three
and yes gotcha cuz I know No
we've got nothing nothing what's that
roll of film 106 now I definitely want
me some 109 all right gonna get those
guys quickly very good
[Music]
106
enter thank you see these one in soon
yep okay all right no no you can do now
sorry I didn't like no you don't have to
do that no sir the other thing hey there
you go
Thanks this isn't particularly secure as
lockers go yeah like I said it redundant
really thank you yeah into the code to
open the locker which Locker which he
like to steal
commemorative photo okay an undeveloped
roll of film so you can't use it it's
already been shot but you know maybe it
may be the station will have a darkroom
okay you know what I'm fine nothing like
it 22 year max good night
fine hi can I just I'm an idiot
that's okay that's fine as long as we
know okay we look what's in the case
do you see this in the case steal steal
boy else what else
Oh a shorty the geronimo useless 104
there we go
no he's not dead man heads missing died
okay all right well that was a waste of
ammo
okay so let's look at the other side so
we've got a rule two or three no
currents that probably should have
looked for words first oh they're all
twos okay so I'm assuming we need a key
card for this it's all right you didn't
get good
okay so leis leis Nicholson says you
guys need to open the safes they're
important mm-hmm yes we will we haven't
had any codes yet okay
it appears that to keep her locker
terminal it's missing a few key suggests
the person responsible for this mess
find some spare keys and fix this right
now you know who you are
bastard I need to start like leaving
pastor grace of Commons in brackets what
part of that is positive aggressive
comments in brackets tougher play notes
please do the dishes brackets you know
who you are you baptized it
okay so safety deposit room we still
have more to do in there obviously yeah
now where can we go I can just continue
up here continue on this way I think
did you pick up any boards yeah hey
there we go wooden boards I don't know
she need them I'm gonna leave that right
here be going do you put the board's
against the window before it breaks it
boards please nicely done thank you
alright
I presume they're not gonna hold forever
because not with us nothing is eternal
camp zombie for friendship but zombies
is good lovely thank you alright so in
terms of graphics cam we have been
basically it's at a steady sort of 150
160 I think kind it throughout getting a
few minor no I'll say just like visual
glitches like that yeah just cuz we have
gone above than there Ram mmm-hmm but in
terms of be able to drop the frame
that's another toilet no it's not it's a
lot longer so that's where they go are
you um peanut locker room we solved it
we solved the mystery Oh different is
different her right that's pink I'm
sorry and that is a pink herb that's
right just blind there's no para that's
red no I would I would describe it as
pink it's me yeah okay so um in terms of
graphic should we should we see if we
can actually hammer this at all but I do
want to have why you put the slider up
to 200 percent this might take a a
moment at the risk of darling up to 11
that let's do that okay red dot sight
also change change the resolution
scaling factor now I understand this to
be and by the way chap please correct me
if I'm wrong that as we increase this
percentage we're essentially rendering
the game for a higher resolution monitor
and then down scaling it again
alright so 20% would be 4k uhd no wait
that's four times sorry
that would be 2k right presumably yes
he'll then that would be 400% yeah 4k
before intercept or us to be man as we
increase this it is really jumping like
you click and then is
to sing Lord and image image quality
going up it is in fact in theory it's
just a fitting oh here we go 43 frames
per second
101 frame no no all right as we go
higher wearing it 200 200 200 19 okay
come on this is basically going to put
me in a real moment of real panic okay
come on we can we can hit 200 see okay
is it possible to go past 300 Jimmy to
check yeah all right no 50 oh we could
able to come back we're going to be in a
much quicker way of doing no I enjoyed
the anticipation all right here we go
okay ladies Nicholson says Oh someone
says you missed a dark room downstairs
go away dark room okay lei says they
missed quite a lot law but they're funny
also they're having fun oh I'll tell you
what look we're the frame rate has
finally settled into traditional sort of
values yeah that's surprising me break
oh it's pretty good
all right I don't think we find a cool
don't sing why don't you try the dark
does it go up to s oh it doesn't know
you kind of say said I wasn't not trying
to do that do you try camp can you write
can I can write can maybe see it see if
it open for can
cap can can it work never had him say
anything it's no fair at all Oh skinny
boys yes do I have space them right no
you don't used to combine your herbs
your birds
oh I could I could find a pamphlet
telling you about herbs or do I make
that I think you may have made that up
on this occasion yeah no I think I find
that combined Oh mixed green and red
herbs huh okay nice delicious
then with the other green as well will
you restore your health probably could
but I think having a small amount of
health recovery might not be a terrible
idea
yeah okay sure use those shoddy shells
what's in the market note zilch a what's
in it
oh oh press a button to light up this
corresponding lamp light at the mall to
open the safe press a button to light
off its corresponding the lamp let's
don't order presents inga but everyone
would call the lights go okay I got done
this yet yeah this sounds like a like
the cuddle the chat is is shouting no no
no I'm sure I'm sure
a mitrice falls you were actually really
close with kam oh was i okay
I'm maybe I will go and check it again
so I can't take this put it back here's
an idea
yeah it's good those stairs to the
darkroom yeah the develop that roll of
film should get rid of it yes face me
with you okay and I'm not gonna open
that because whatever we find in there I
won't be able to take anyway yeah okay
so we're heading back downstairs yeah to
the darkroom to the daiquiri gotcha
Oh what did I make just say one PA let's
get that reticule running running quick
time quick return do I need to kill him
no so so that guy just broke the glass
because he put the board's there you're
fine okay
all right oh yeah yeah just um in the
end just stood up while he's crawling
still like Oh first me show his leg off
them that's me oh he was already dead I
think he's dead for God's sake okay wait
so we've we've lost her a few redundant
rounds I'd say about three years she's
doing really well on every weighted
round so far let's have a look at the
map where is this dark room the chat is
currently just putting in the codes for
all the safes in the game chat I
appreciate you guys are so nice but we
don't we don't need your help okay we
don't need it anyone home close the door
I know a little bit about dark rooms and
they don't like to be liked that's
that's true alright that was a big
somewhere green herbs heal a basic
injury blue have long been treated for
poisoning as for red they are visually
appealing they offer no medical benefits
or so it was thought until recently it's
knowing that combining herbs together
juices blends that heightens their
effects but it has been discovered that
red herbes can play a big role when
mixed properly okay
fair another when red produces a blend
strengths and strengthens ones
Constitution okay got it
really we've only just begun to realize
that that is true that is this really
tree Oh typewriter I will do bathe once
a please nice thank you okay so what do
we got we have a storage cupboard
oh this transports yeah they're there
they're linked okay so well why are you
just going to your film I'm gonna do
exactly that you put your Stevie boys in
there I was thinking of doing that but
I'll get to that in a bit so I switch
for the darkroom do I presume you want
that off for I imagine so have you ever
tried developing film and a bright
darkroom
I actually haven't ever tried developing
film no I'd love to try I have once a
long time ago that's where the terms
come from like dodging and yeah your
burning burning yeah yeah gotcha
commemorates advice a beautifully
rendered he did a great job okay
Oh Oh what's he got what's he got lace
with a gemstone in it and and a boat can
I say maybe I can't zoom in any more
than that either that's right okay okay
mmm do we get to keep the photo oh no
you don't know so we need to see the
picture yeah you saw it you got it okay
all right I'll have this herb take the
herb do we think so you haven't been to
the you haven't been yet to the sorry
the office yeah like really owns desk is
so I'm confused I thought you would have
been their name but open your map for me
Bob okay now I know we haven't been to
the what did you miss
so I'm not being any east officer oh
yeah yeah we never written in East
office so I go back it's easy to yeah
yeah I mean um you can just stuff did
the stuff to get in there actually I
think the seized officer is at the West
is there a West office let's have a look
yeah there is yeah where's office yeah
it's the West off essentially where no
no he missed up
well it's just crossing so let's see
what happens okay so I'm going to store
my
shotgun shells for now okay and should I
store the red herb or you can combine it
with a green yeah I'm just wondering if
I need saved for a blue oh yeah story oh
the best be good okay
onwards open lockers what was that okay
I'm gonna store that because like my shy
story came by to I can possibly say I'm
gonna store it we've only got one slot
left yeah this is some this is some good
management of the old limited inventory
let's not Oh green hair well yes of
course again probably worth storing just
cuz I know this stuff upstairs so let's
do that okay you store Thanks okay all
right I'm gonna try and dress on shall I
go to the east office so I go to the
West West okay it's just running here
somewhere look back the way you came
anything yes it is back the way I came
Oh God that's all b-boy board somehow it
is Oh what okay okay say maybe it was
the East office then where cuz in the
Leon's desk chat am I right in thinking
is it the East office where Leon's desk
is well that seems to be the only way in
from here cuz I knew I know there's
something you can get which would be
helpful no caring that in the office
well I can head head back
No mmm no you know what you can just
pick us onward so you go you're gonna
have to go back that way of inch okay
okay you know in risen evolve there's a
lot of chewing and throwing yeah just
kind of briefly lost my way all right we
got map so I guess back upstairs right
that's where you were making good
progress we pass this chat every time
mate yeah this is this is holding steady
pretty pretty well pretty much there
well it kind of depends on what what the
action is at any given time
I know we've not got a lot going on
right now so we're all happy that we're
done with the locker room okay so do you
want me to try and you Matt I'm gonna
try and bust through the the code okay
okay if they said that I was closer can
although they actually literally said
where was I said it was okay I know I'm
just gonna see it it is cab it is cat
why did you think it was cat I don't
know because I was like what else could
it be that narrow thing it's obviously
obviously it's cat
oh for Capcom yeah forget it it is the
other one calm it must be there must be
one this comp somewhere that's like
coming through the windows well we are a
few stories up there mate don't even say
it
there's there's gotta be some things
that climb okay oh they were just
throwing ammo on you
well I'm gonna throw it back at them I
had like no exploding point so there's
also this okay someone want to explain
oh is that you gotcha they got you there
you go you calm calm I guess not calm
I'll be shot no it's not calm cap cap
cap cap cap can okay okay mm-hmm Bob
Jones has a lot of face nuts faith in us
he says how they died yet Ryan says it's
west office I think it's definitely on
this side station I have the key I got
speed I've got the Spade please all
right okay
can I go through you know where where is
here oh it's new territory god what was
that
what I think that was not your average
sabe
no I think I remember what lay says the
code was DAC M period DCM I was gonna
say what DCM then we'll cry maybe yeah
exactly yeah
I've not been here yet boards a venturi
you know what you know what I actually
haven't here and I'm gonna suggest that
you push on further in this room before
you start making stuff okay all right
gotcha
because you might find something in here
that's gonna help
or is it Roos only right buddy look up
goddamn way I didn't know it's gonna hi
actually didn't know that's gonna happen
will he grab you if he if you walk in
his hands wait he's cool I didn't mean
through here but you can you're starting
to get the point where you can play this
much again okay
there is definitely something in here
that I find that's gonna be helpful to
you alright so not the sea it's not the
sea for yet some guys scribblings yes
really helpful okay I'm those corporate
[ __ ] that cut me off after all I've
done for them but if that's how it's
gonna be so beard I'm gonna have a
little fun of my own in this world DJ
okay I've already all these oh my
goodness I boarded all these filthy pigs
up and steel pen and set some c4 Wow
okay so Fisk sir but it's no fun if it's
over teasing so maybe I'll give that one
rating means something to really squeal
about yeah maybe I'll give him a little
toy and tell him kill the guy next to
you and I'll spare the others wow dude
who did this you yell about justice and
pride about how many times you get to do
mmm
this guy sounds awful yeah Wow wow
that's dark yeah but that is a bag a hip
pouch oh yes two extra inventory slot
okay not a big hip house but a hit pouch
nonetheless mm-hmm
okay so that's c4 but it kind of looks
like everyone in here is already dead
how would you detonate c4 needs
gunpowder ah yes
no I need you to run past a few things
you know yeah that's right Oh first load
up on some ammo
okay sure there's definitely like three
zombies then you've run past two haven't
activated that my knife thumb and they
came alive so that's what happens on my
ammo okay
I provoked a bunch of fights with
zombies that apparently didn't you
didn't need to all right so I'm gonna
take some gunpowder and I'm gonna
totally take these boards there you go
now you're tooled up go batter a boards
cam I feel like exploding things it's
probably gonna test our frame rate for
the first time probably can you give us
a rundown of the specs of the obelisk c4
yeah I know there's nothing about c4
okay Connie some can you combine with
the key out of the boards I don't think
I can combine gunpowder with anything
coming hmm maybe you need a bet there'll
be a detonator but you'll find it in
here somewhere a bit okay okay I don't
know where but I haven't found it I'm
just guessing okay all right well I mean
we've got more exploring today and I
feel like I progressed quite far quite
suddenly yeah say maybe you'll find it
down here maybe I will
oh then can I go down there
so ya can give me the give me more give
me the spec it's important that I'll be
right there think he might be his own
big thought that was them oh no you did
this is all B's down there okay okay you
ready jump can I jump I can't okay so I
can't go that way I might have to run
through them new doctor sure but you
know it's no oh yes I did yes I needed
to jump okay we're down run or use your
mo want to see what's going on hey I'm a
I probably am actually gonna use a
little bit of a statue new puzzle
alright you see it ready to shoot all
the zombies who come through
no doggy's country every time the door
the door banging is really light no he's
backed back not done way I'm just going
from the hotel
waste shoot her again shoot her again
you'll double tap no she's still moving
Seth
I think she might just be glitch glitch
it she is okay a puzzle I can solve this
take your notebook will do Bob Bob
Johnson I think he says living
dangerously now when you jump down there
I didn't mean to unicorn I would say it
was a full fish scorpion jug the old
fish scorpion joke yeah fish
was there a scorpion yes one unicorn
medallion coin thank you okay mate do we
need the board's I feel like the boards
are quite useful we don't we really need
this key green herb yeah I'm gonna you
gonna have to discard it though oh I do
I have to discard it and then you go
discard and then you're never getting
this back and you'll have to go back all
right it's good okay well let's just say
that I would have used it before when I
would have gotten hurt I liked him he
was like Leon hurry back you're like
I'll be right there
I'm just gonna collect some coins first
that's got things going on you know okay
so let's look at the map so you need to
go out to the main hall so if you go
back in the library there is a door
there that you can open with a spade key
on the right okay
so yeah this door was previously to the
right yeah that was previously locked
with a spade key so he should in theory
but this is where I came from
yeah so there should be a door there you
can go through that one yes I see it
there in the exit sign zombie uh nom be
nom be Oh
new knife I swap it swap it not a way to
just I think you just did no let's try
it again
so can I ever entries full no I've got
to do it manually
I really hope you're gonna pick a knife
up there if you're gonna discard this
discard he needs it not you one not you
knife oh you know what I barely use the
other one yeah I thought I had nothing
left but actually it was just barely
used okay so carelessly walking over his
own potential zombie I feel like we were
about to discuss the specs of the PC and
then I got really scared when you fell
through the floor say yes okay so the
specs of this pc that's because you can
see we've we've cranked the graphics you
even pushed
what are we pushing 200 percent so 200%
with everything on full yeah and the 200
set was the image quality right so we've
we've raised it up twice technical terms
so yeah the inside this guy is an Intel
i7 8700 it's a six-course CPU running on
a boosted 4 4 6 gigahertz yes it's base
clock is 3.2 right but it will boost all
the way up to 4.6 so if I were to jump
on this you would see very much that it
is running yeah so that's why the thing
is red and it's red at the moment
because we've currently got the the omen
command center to show the graphics card
yes that's of course yeah when it's
running at its highest
well basically stress you can do a whole
load of like color oh wait you know what
let's let's see what's gonna happen here
he had important news yeah I think he is
the most coherent zombie we've seen so
far yes I knew she'd make it
oh it's Claire yeah yeah that's Claire
name's Claire I came into town with her
you can get to that courtyard do the
second floor decide
he's very nearly as I'm on it he's gonna
be fine lieutenant
howling so I did check if you could
shoot him there
yeah you can you can't
yeah but it didn't put it in didn't put
it in please all right
one the guy we're getting there we are
getting we're getting there okay yes sir
we can continue it's also go back to the
east office now by the way now that I've
returned yet okay to these 16 gigabytes
of HyperX around it does yes and it's so
we mentioned already that it's running a
it's got inside it and video r-tx to
80/20 80/20 80
you can't go back through because that
got oh no can you can you push the
button push the button this button
that's already being pulled yeah you
have to go oh you can go on the second
floor though okay then go down Oh
because that's where you just told you
to go but you haven't got the shotgun
yet and I can see it won't let me
through there yeah but the shotgun is
this side in the same item or you can do
the safe deposit room okay so I can't so
I I'm not being crazy right okay I can
definitely not crawl through here and no
you can't you can okay okay well let's
just hope for the best
I wonder what I don't think it was in
the east side so go back to your mouth
okay so I'm trying to figure out where
this room was I'm very confused
can you get into the West office the
records room maybe there's a records
room
you haven't been in there either I can
certainly try you know okay I assume red
is locked door right I don't been well
yes I guess it must be or challenging
door of some sort yeah there is a door
again I'm going to use use every time I
think no it'll be open
okay here we go progress oh this is it
welcome Leon this is where I was yeah
yeah yeah okay okay I'm good for welcome
Leon that's me Leon
Scott don't you forget it rookies first
assignment yeah covered in blood
Leon Scott Kennedy we're putting you on
a very special case for your first
assignment your mission is to unlock
your desk okay success is in the
initials of our first names and put the
letters in order of our desks there are
two locks one on each side of your desk
make sure you get them both okay this is
a fairly fairly straightforward task
scroll down and corner because of drops
of blood be glad you're not here Ricky
okay so we solved okay so let's look at
some desk names so we've got David Ford
there is again David Ford our operations
report so catchy name okay officer
Phillips once suggested we escape
Elliott Edward okay but that was three
that was three
[Music]
that's how we do it quick Oh missed
missed at point-blank range
this guy's Hardy Oh justify knife please
thanks for all the way there for me yeah
super damage we're safe okay so I
presume I still can't do this we don't
have any codes yet oh all right locker
another word zombie inside no just
bullets to say let's say knew what to
expect
okay so David for Eliot for you I think
there's another zombie in this room that
you just haven't seen okay
just FYI you mean this guy
you mean maybe that guy oh yes of course
with the reloading their gun especially
with obvious in your face over here
these cops are all for shudders I think
I was civilian a knife please
oh she's hurt she's real bad more
gunpowder can I combine again hey miles
that's what okay oh no no no here--like
gunpowder attempts to go murder plus
high-grade gunpowder it's yellow for
shotgun hi Green County
and just an interest day okay great
okay so storing that gunpowder was
absolutely pointless and what else have
we got we've got Neil Carlson so david
forward Eliot Edwards sir it's just
first names only
so David's d.o may be the other way
around so Neil David that's her Eliot
David no hey how we doing okay so it's
like it's in order of coming closer I
guess II gotta say we've got Rita and
George just killed yeah so George George
Rita
Marvin George are are Marvin sorry
Marvin okay Rita and George merge merge
success you know you're gonna get it's a
zombie zombie it's a high capacity man
thank you
and a nameplate BAE Matilda's got a gun
more bullets named Leon s Kennedy nice
to hang a big sign that right that is
more effort than I've ever made for any
of my loved ones let alone a colleague
yeah yeah where's my work I'm married I
just I just came back from holiday where
was my Welcome Week am saying I was
making it I was making it I swear
all right oh okay wait that's where you
left all the blood so is this so this is
a room I just didn't think to go in yeah
yeah I think gotcha
but you you went the other way no I did
say the Carter er I've not really spent
much time maybe it's to say anything is
there is a decent chance it's the safe
okay we lured the high magno says Bob
Jones hitting he actually has reloaded
okay no no you have to get the gunite
first let's try all right oh yeah if
you've got 24 bills you're good you're
good okay
24 that is a mag yeah and you got 29 to
spare you 20 too many bullets okay so do
we want to leave this max settings like
this or should we dial it back again I
think it's performing right I mean it's
performing well for now hmm let's see
so West office we think it's probably
just through he said that you need to go
to the East upper floor to get Claire
help Claire in mm-hmm
but I'm worried that we've left the
shotgun but how did was on we needed a
car key car didn't we we did need a key
card yes maybe it's fine it means we've
not seen we could try and get into the
records room because that is that door
looks like it's a records room we're
going okay it's away that's check yes
all right out here hang a left and left
again okay this map is super useful left
again nope no it's straight on which I
can't go up and through maybe the
operations room yeah we could do this no
no that way no can I go through here oh
no how do we get there again we did you
have to go back in the way you came
through reception okay yeah
and there's nothing else I can get from
here once again safe codes hopefully
well we are I mean it's what is it 6:45
now hmm I'm going to look at slightly
over to my colleague from GameSpot who
is going to indicate if we should go
until 7:00 and she's giving me the
thumbs up all right 15 minutes 15
minutes let's let's let's slack off this
let this progress the story let's go
back to what Marvin said so we're
heading to the East Wing
East Wing it is Marv we're gonna listen
to you okay you're the boss Marv oh
there we go so heading back I presume I
just want to head up the stairs and yeah
well there's a speed another speed key
upstairs there is so let's go through
the West office that seems to be like a
decent no West office is here that's
right okay heading back back into the
main hall alright let's head up the
stairs kandi nice
okay okay and scared all right well
that's where we want to progress through
we've got to say a lot of banging is it
have you seen our a save point in your
oh there is actually a save point not
right here so I guess we're not saving
no just go through okay maybe it's
friends hey you know what I'm actually
pretty sure it is organized items okay
the other boss
oh he's telling you that you don't need
that key anymore oh really yeah it's got
a red take on it you can just okay come
on said push the right buttons yeah it's
not right like it which okay I did that
bunch
we don't actually like discard an item
that is a key item wherever you like you
can do is
I'm scared be scared I'm driving
Oh God that sounded fine
maybe maybe everyone's fine what was
that
I see dust over here so I'm gonna follow
that Gary did he shoot things I mean I'm
not 100% sure
oh my god I think it might be that this
here helicopter hey pal yeah okay zombie
zombie or zombie he season on me at the
moment
he looks fairly just yeah great regular
all day actually quick turn more okay
all right we're out oh wait we did it we
gonna well I mean she's down there she
she's fine hold on right there in the
game okay
oh no zombie blaming zombie he's gonna
be a flaming zombie clear open the gate
open the gate this is the look right
there Leon had one date throw it away no
like how are you what's saying what's
new with you
hey there's definitely something there's
definitely some light flirting with you
brother
how's he brother has he mom yeah yeah
well that's great to hear
I'm sure we're gonna find him
unless that was pretty big fire right
damn it
pretty good still 50 frames what that
means yeah yeah
oh say the fact that we're running this
Brendan at 200% means first yeah feels
to me like we could probably safely run
this game at higher resolution now than
been in the 1080p Montevideo
look at the zombies not Leon okay so
chill but we can use the cutting tool
bolt cutters did you notice Lee he's
reading Marvin Marvin at a range
Marvin's a zombie we are out of range
cam and I think I'm not here it
hey you can now go through the door
thing so yeah what I'm saying is that I
think because we've been able to safely
run this rendered at 200 percent yeah
that we would probably be able to wrong
oh I reckon we could run the game of for
get watch out for Jimmy other zombie you
yeah I'm just gonna go however now let's
go into the room that we can go into
before I believe this is being east
office
in fact I'm certain of it oh yeah
oh wow one short hit heads flower that's
what we like what's that that looks like
a fuse I'm no peas expert in electrical
parts fuse expert Oh dad or haze in door
other one there is this guy he's like
sweaty too huh oh I think my oh thank
you I believe my knife got destroyed so
I'm I'm not gonna be able to get that
back so basically that means that was my
last panic of the day which is good
because we are down to minus 10 minutes
okay I will take the herb though because
we are getting dangerously close to
getting awful
but bite me once shame on you might be
twice the more time shame on me go cheat
Oh God shoot an exception except except
shoot him shoot more that's fine it's
fine can you man you need to chill out
better okay I didn't you shouldn't use
the first date sprain and safe -
whatever that's okay I'll go freeing up
all of our friends Oh God giant zombie
if there is a critic looking at all
I wonder why was there a reason maybe
it's put there for a reason
perhaps for a chance well you're all
high heels so now no they all right get
a nice good see this guy when he's big
boy got him what we like how you do it
that's how you do okay do any of you
have any healing items and or ammunition
I'm asking for a friend
oh that's the steam for the steam that
is for the steam 100 percent right
handle well in more positive rays your
lots of real estate in our you can mix
our concerns and make shotgun shells we
don't need the wrench we don't want to
board that but you can I mean I know
I've used up all my boards so do you
reckon that's this room done I reckon so
it isn't but does this room out here it
does not it does not count you staying
there's more stuff in here somewhere
if any of these zombies aren't actually
dead that was some least good work okay
alright so we should we combo wombo for
some shoddy shells why not done you can
combo wombo your shot you
- the same the same oh did I have some
an idea of course yeah cool all right
no still no actually look again
hey sure you what's in the room what is
that some kind of grenade looking thing
you need I couldn't say I'm walking away
from it
Oh a zombie just moved where do you
write - you're right he's getting it oh
no I just saw you know funny - I think
it's getting to me okay
yeah space ready right gotcha
cool all right now we're done
ayyyy great good Joe should we head back
to the main hall um see what's shaking
see how much of a zombie Marvin is now
he won't be a zombie man like he's gonna
be fine okay okay say oh one fuse please
he's fine man
Marvin Marvin Marvin don't do this to me
Marv safe hey Margo just gonna save
quickly I'm looking for my good friend
Marvin have you seen him is he behind it
no I hear you yes he's fine still alive
still alive you're right you're right I
wonder if this is like maybe he survives
the entire game I reckon he will I know
your pessimism it's not welcoming it's
just like beating you to think he's
gonna be a zombie every time you come
back then he never is been here so I'm
looking for ways we can progress now so
upstairs but the steam upstairs of
course yes it's me it's not actually a
steam room is it the room had the steam
yes let's go there I mean it may be a
steam room I don't know I mean like okay
so that was on the west side yes the
west side of this police station has a
sauna it's very nice in here this might
be one way to get there anyway you have
to go back upstairs though so that was
the puzzle room that we did yeah there's
actually more we can move through the
puzzle room as well what sir
yeah okay so I'm presuming we can't go
through over that hole now no but you
can't go through this door anything down
the end here
say back through the door oh yeah
dangling friend you've definitely grown
in confidence you were you were edging
your way around the game earlier and now
you're just like clashing about
sprinting I heard his own be think I
just been the guns breathing oh boy I
still still plenty of stress nice that
this is the little statue room yeah yeah
it's down one floor I think Ashley okay
steam room besides seeing things
oh I'm hearing things
alright that's enough of you steam nice
okay all right well let's let's see what
we can achieve in here it is very nearly
seven o'clock cam yep see if we can oh
that's a zombie no [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh the corpse my bad sorry it's it's
good to check more gunpowder always
always welcome police officers keep the
Gunpowder in there law sometimes you
just need it he's gone
exploding girls
that's new right this is we haven't been
here but we have not been here whereby
these stars always living room
spiel boys yeah still nowhere it's still
nice shotgun day all right well it's two
minutes to seven steps so I think fine
one more somebody kill I will all right
okay Oh perfect
oh heavens Oh heaven Olga oh this is
gonna pour leak a bit you need a shotgun
I think maybe a shotgun would have done
really face put the grenade inside yes
yes please explain please explode oh
dear still monster you
you can sneak past them things have gone
poorly there and quick turn to death
okay right one minute to 7:00 that was
perfect you are right all right that's
it
thanks everybody for for what sure yeah
well done sir I'll be this is gonna be
this gonna sound like damning with faint
praise but we did very well
terrible actually you're better than me
in this game you keep your cool better I
cannot say that anything about what I
just did there was no the ends at the
end but the rest of it my my right yeah
yeah we I've set this to medium so that
it's not like absolutely Arctic it is
nice
great yeah that's nice and cold nice and
cold but anyway yes so this has been our
Resident Evil 2 stream brought to you by
omen by HP they have provided all the
equipment you've seen here so we were
playing on the Ovilus gaming desktop PC
and we've got the HD sorry the 25 inch
display which basically runs at 144
Hertz gaming basically yeah we've got
the sequencer keyboard and the reactor
mouse and how your hands feeling after
getting ninety minutes not well okay my
hands are sweaty unfortunately that's
more to do with no oh yeah yeah a mouse
but the but yeah it I it runs the game
so well I mean yeah I know it's just
sitting there at 72 frames per second
running it effectively 4k we've up
scaled it internally using the graphic
systems but yeah even when we pushed it
past its supposed limits it was running
really very well well thank you everyone
as well for watching and for throwing in
those questions and many many safe codes
in the chat we appreciate them yeah hope
you hope you enjoyed and of course for
more on Resident Evil 2 make sure you
come back to gain support calm
[Music]